when we first meet it's almost as if we
we have our noses on each other right
um an aviation phrase meaning that like
you're you're ready to attack the other
person right you got your nose on
someone right so you can you can fire
he's looking at me and I resemble a lot
of the guys who have tried to hurt him
over the course of his his Naval
Aviation career we're on the same side
you know but we have our noses on each
other we're trying to figure out who's
who what's what Tom hudner was about as
blue blood as they call me was on his
way to Harvard when he decided I'm going
to become a Naval aviator and uh Jesse
Brown was the son of a sharecropper who
through nothing but his own
extraordinary talent and dedication
managed to become
one of our most talented Naval aviators
in the first black Navy year that we had
in our country's history and um coming
from such disparate worlds is that these
two men met and formed a friendship and
a bond
that was then to play out in one of the
most extraordinary acts of heroism in
the history of Naval Aviation in the
history of our military